hey I was gonna brush my name is my name
is my name is what my name is who my
name is Jake Jake Jake Jake Jake hey
Jake all right and welcome to photoshop
with Peter pie one of the most exciting
shows on YouTube because you are
involved you're coming with along this
is like Dora the Explorer but some
next-level [ __ ] this girl wants to
become a platypus no wait penguin I
always mix them up a penguin you say
let's do this
um no this looks great I can probably
like tell a difference all right you
know what Penguin has long noses right
make it happen
now penguins don't have ice so let's get
rid of those
I just realized Penguin has ice this
just in
penguins aren't eyeless so we're gonna
just sample this I here and just put it
right there yeah no you know I think we
got something here um looks yeah no that
looks pretty good I would rate this ten
out of ten probably on IMDb take okay
here's the platypus Luke farm chiona
wants to be a platypus I hear they're
really like dangerous like they could
eat off your face or some [ __ ] is that
true
this is quality there you go let's let's
put that there
now that Alex that looks good that looks
really good
okay fingers they look a bit different
don't day let's transplant their fingers
this is a very delicate procedure we
have to do it quite right and it's gone
you're welcome my child my sweet child
you're a platypus see from now on take
take I'm handsome Photoshop me solid ass
I don't really understand that sentence
to be fully honest and I don't really
appreciate you sending me nude pictures
of you in the shower even though I don't
technically see the rest genius idea I
got a genius idea look at these muscles
he has double biceps he has really
awkwardly big nipples which you know
what you can do surgery around that so
don't worry my sweet child and I think
that's a hammer as a hand he is packing
though so that's okay it's not a good
likes proportion but I mean I'm I bet a
lot of ladies will like it he has bigger
tits than my mother okay
yes I'm so sorry what's your name Dennis
but I hope you appreciate it
hey hey uh Andrea preeeetty wants to
become liquor tongue
what's the liquor tongue holy [ __ ] the
things I do for your press I see so many
people but uh PewDiePie doesn't care
about his fans yeah well do other
youtubers do this [ __ ] for their fans
uh-huh don't think so uh-huh no no that
looks really creepy ah
let's make his ice dead while we're at
it hey take I want to become a sexy
person just remove the little blemishes
there you go these eyebrows you should
probably pluck them a little bit like
that give you a little bit a more
accentuated high color your nose is
beautiful uh it is little big look at
this look at this
there's nothing wrong with trying out
new things that's what we're doing here
like don't worry about it this is what
they do to superstars
all right you have great lips you know
what let me just say that very kissable
I don't want to go near them but I'm
sure lady ladies will man you have great
eyes dude uh they look a little [ __ ]
up that's entirely my fault you look
kind of like a crack addict uh because
of me not you girls may like it yeah
girls may like it oh my god you're go
coup
it has been revealed Coco my child Coco
let's do one more
one Agoura grande finale as I like to
say we have Miriam Falcon Singh she
wants to become fabulous a great way to
become fabulous really fast and as what
I like to recommend to a lot of clients
is just add chintz it's that simple
it's that simple I'm scared bros I'm
scared
uh help help me someone help me it's
taking over the chance that chance
alright price we're gonna have to end
that episode there they black me enjoy
brothers as always stay awesome yeah I
always wish I just became a plastic
surgeon cuz I really think I have a
knack for these things
just tell my god